what was the process of recording this
probably less training than Street
Fighter Emma's yeah no training you just
go in and your crappy clothes you know
but it's a different beast I mean voice
recording is so specific whereas as an
actor I like rely on my my face in my
body and like I can feel something and
it can come across in many different
ways but with voice acting it's all very
specifically around your voice so
getting really specific around that's
challenging but it's really fun it's a
weird environment where you have a bunch
of weirdos in a room doing weird noises
and you feel ridiculous
I feel like how do you get yourself
amped up for should I feel like you're
doing a lot of fighting scenes well you
do the fighting scenes separate so you
do all of your efforts
have you seen that video of Hugh Jackman
doing his Wolverine ADR looping oh no
yeah I think it was for Logan I don't
run anyway he's like in a room and he's
like like he does crazy I shouldn't say
that but crazy stuff and so that's sort
of what it's like you're in a room
making like efforts so if you're jumping
you have to do a liftoff so like oh like
all this kind of this was weird and you
kill your voice a little bit but you do
it all at once and then they can use it
in different spots well what do you
think what would you do if someone was
punching you
well Jimmy you got a liftoff okay so is
your land like why would you late it's
like an exhale I don't know if I make a
noise and I lands in place but if you
were not being seen then it was just a
picture yes you'd be like huh depending
on how far the fall is you know yeah
this was a very physical interview and
how long does that take how long is the
process
I don't remember how long we took
multiple day like five days I'm guessing
I can't remember so there's like three
episodes to the saga and I think and and
that's how long I took but there are
other people that come in at other times
and I'm not sure exactly how long they
ended up recording for no Fan Expo today
yes yeah different kind of crowd what
are you expecting today I don't know I
have literally not thought about it a
ton because I've been working so I'm
expecting people who love things Fan
Expo is full of fans and they are
passionate and I've been in you know the
fantasy sci-fi realm for a long time for
most of my career so these are people
who have you know really supported so
much of the stuff that I've that I've
been a part of and they're amazing do
you find that people it's more
smallville pizza more beating the beast
people like wouldn't get recognized for
it I'll generally get recognized for
Smallville still and I think it just
started airing again recently on Hulu
and the states and then I noticed people
in Canada like young people are like I
just started watching Smallville I'm
like oh my god I feel so old
both those shows that both us was a
hugely popular but they both still exist
in pop culture and other yes totally
right if you find it weird to see now
other combinations of Superman or no but
it's funny hey when you look at the CW
now like we started when I was back when
it was the WB and we were the first
superhero show and it was a very
different vibe very different I mean I
think if you watch Smallville now it's
so innocent compared to what's out there
now I'm like oh gosh we were so there
are they gonna kiss so it was it's kind
of funny to see that now like the CW's
main programming is DC Comics which is
awesome and it's weird that we started
look we were kind of ahead of that trend
yeah do you watch the new ones now if
you see the new Beauty the Beast like
the new musical I did you know what I
did watch that one at home one day
because I was a kid I loved that that
movie so I know I know pretty much all
the words to all the songs which I'm not
going to sing you cuz I'm a terrible
sight
no but we sing along to that an entire
movie sadly but yeah I did watch that
one yeah this is a weird scene no
because it's totally different right
like what we were doing was based on the
Linda Hamilton show from the 80s and it
was and our version was entirely
different so it's like it's a totally
different beast I know the word that
came to my head